[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
hoy nos acompaña el señor Félix Ulloa
vicepresidente del Salvador Señor
gracias por estar con nosotros es un
gusto usted está aquí en el marco de la
cumbre iberoamericana en la
representación de su país de El Salvador
Cómo se ha sentido recibido en este
encuentro es como estar en casa muy bien
atendidos un pueblo amigo gobierno muy
eficiente Así es que todo ha salido muy
bien Sí pero me refiero más bien A cómo
se ha sentido recibido por parte de los
representantes o sea de los otros países
asistentes a la Cumbre Y es que pues
usted viene en representación de un país
que ha estado en el centro mediático y
también en el centro de las críticas
bueno de las críticas de algunos medios
tendenciosos del país de España es un
periódico que tiene una campaña
permanente contra el presidente bukele y
contra su gobierno pero
el revés hemos tenido la mayor
aceptación en todas partes aquí en
Dominicana en Chile en Argentina en
Uruguay donde hemos estado recientemente
estuvimos en la congreso lag y en todas
partes hemos tenido una recibimiento
excelente de hecho esta ayer o Antier
estaba el director de la Policía
Nacional Civil del Salvador en Chile en
una reunión de Interpol donde se le
llamó para que fuera a compartir la
experiencia de nuestros países o sea que
las críticas que siempre van a ver es
una crítica minoritaria de los sectores
minoritarios que
dan eco a las críticas de los grupos
minoritarios en El Salvador que son
parte de la oposición política Entonces
eso es natural ahorita en el mundo hay
una buque alemanía Entonces por supuesto
la imagen del presidente bukele genera
mucha simpatías y más que alguna crítica
así que por esa parte estamos muy bien
entonces ha habido países que se le han
acercado en el marco de esta Cumbre a
felicitarle bueno no Era ese el objetivo
porque no no estamos acá para tratar
haciendo relaciones públicas Veníamos a
resolver Y a declarar toda una serie de
principios de decisiones que se habían
estado trabajando en los equipos de más
importantísimo como el rediseño de la
internacional del financiamiento temas
relacionados con casos de soberanía por
ejemplo reconocer la malvinas son
argentinas Yo sé que no estaba la Cumbre
montada para hablar de El Salvador pero
como usted dice que ha sido muy bien
recibido le pregunto si precisamente ha
habido países que le han venido a
felicitar o a decirle que sus políticas
son una inspiración para ellos más de
algunos sí es decir porque el caso de la
República Dominicana por ejemplo dimos
la noticia de que atendiendo el llamado
que se ha hecho en múltiples foros la
República Dominicana de que ayudemos a
resolver el caso de Haití El Salvador
respondió yo anunciaba el día de ayer
que en un intercambio de notas entre el
Primer Ministro de Haití Ariel enríe y
el presidente bukele se ha logrado ya el
acuerdo para establecer una oficina del
Salvador en Haití porque lo decía ayer
de nuevo el presidente de República
Dominicana Don Luis avión nadar que es
tiempo de pasar de las declaraciones y
pasar a la acción decir la acción en
Haití hay que ir insistía él mucho
porque para República Dominicana es un
problema casi nacional la crisis
haitiana y cuando Precisamente en
relación a esta oficina que ustedes han
anunciado que van a abrir en Haití cuál
sería exactamente la función y cuando la
van a abrir bueno se va a abrir cuando
terminemos las conversaciones entre las
cancillerías para establecer los
protocolos de intercambio garantías
diplomáticas inmunidades etcétera una
vez termine ese proceso administrativo
la oficina se va a abrir y se va a abrir
justamente una en el plató central en la
zona de ancho y va a tener como
función principalmente un trabajo de
carácter humanitario y de cooperación O
sea no van a enviar ustedes efectivos
militares o policías de El Salvador
Haití
a quien se le ocurre eso hijo que les
van a que les van a enseñar Bueno vamos
a hablar estoy hablando que son temas de
carácter humanitario y de cooperación en
el tema de seguridad que también nos lo
ha pedido el gobierno haitiano les hemos
ofrecido
toda el know de nuestros proyectos
planes y programas de Seguridad
Ciudadana Comenzando por el plan maestro
que se llama plan Control territorial
que consta de siete etapas y queremos
compartirlo con los amigos de Haití para
que ellos puedan con sus propios
recursos y bajo su propia realidad
implementar estas metodologías porque no
se trata que El Salvador está exportando
su modelo es un modelo exitoso y no solo
Haití No lo ha pedido y otros países que
también ha estado mostrando interés Perú
Honduras han solicitado y han llegado
visitas a Salvador para conocer del del
modelo el trabajo bajo el gobierno del
actual presidente desde antes de ese
gobierno está porque ella era
vicepresidenta cuando hablamos del tema
justamente en la toma de Posesión del
presidente de Costa Rica el año pasado
hablamos del tema para porque les
interesaba ellos al ver los logros que
se estaban obteniendo en El Salvador y
nos planteó la posibilidad de que
pudiéramos tener ese intercambio con con
su gobierno con el gobierno peruano Pero
te digo no solo es Perú son muchos otros
los estados que están mostrando el
interés y están pidiendo que hagamos una
especie de
asesoría técnica nosotros para que este
modelo pudiera tener ese carácter
general y no tener que estarlo tratando
bilateralmente lo ofrecimos al
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
usted me ha hablado de Perú de Honduras
que otros países
por razones de estado Pues no te puedo
decir todos los nombres es decir tú
tendré que tener eso
y precisamente usted habla de este
modelo Cómo se logra detener 64.000
personas que ustedes acusan de
terroristas en un año en nosotros no los
acusamos es decir ellos pertenecen a
estructuras terroristas que tampoco
Nosotros hemos declarado que son
terroristas que es una declaración que
se ha hecho en legislaciones anteriores
Y que 64.000 que no son esos son ya más
de 65.000 han sido capturados durante
todo este año que lleven vigencia el
régimen de excepción y la forma de
capturarlos pues como actúan los cuerpos
de seguridad decir tenemos una base de
datos en la cual hay no solo el perfil
del de los terroristas de los criminales
sino que también la información
necesaria para poder ir a las regiones a
la zona a las comunidades donde ellos
aterrorizaban a la población Entonces se
ha llegado se han hecho Las capturas
masivas porque capturar cinco mil
personas en un año es una tarea y una
operación de magnitud que ningún otro
país en tiempos de paz la ha realizado y
sobre todo sin pagar consecuencias
graves de decir que han habido
enfrentamientos que han habido muertos
porque la operación ha sido impecable
las fuerzas del orden han llegado con
los listados de las personas
directamente capturarlos y los que han
huido o han escapado la misma población
ya que confía de nuevo en las fuerzas
del orden nos ha dicho donde se esconden
nos han indicado para dónde se han ido
pero usted habla de un trabajo que
califican de impecable Sin embargo que
ha recibido pues muchísimas críticas por
las vulneraciones que supone de ciertos
a derechos fundamentales y es que hay
unas 3000 a 500 por ejemplo pendientes
de resolver qué le dice a los familiares
a estas personas Bueno yo no le puedo
decir nada porque no lo han presentado
la vez cuerpos al gobierno
representante de un gobierno que es el
que ha aplicado este régimen de
exclusión
ante la Corte Suprema de Justicia es la
justicia la que va a resolver Y este
cuando tú dices hay muchas no sé cuáles
son muchas porque yo las que he oído son
de dos o tres ongs internacionales que
hacen eco de las ong de El Salvador que
reportan estos casos de para contestar
tu pregunta concretamente ya el informe
de la procuradora de derechos humanos de
Salvador anunciaba esta semana que más
de tres mil personas ya fueron liberadas
O sea la persona que lograron demostrar
que no tenían vínculos con las pandillas
y que por lo tanto pues no tenía porque
estar detenida Y usted por lo tanto
Si considera que todo se ha hecho de
forma impecable no sin Reproches usted
permitiría que la prensa entrara a
hablar con las personas que están
prisioneras en su llamado centro
confinamiento del terrorismo bueno eso
no depende tampoco de mí es que eso yo
creo que hay una pequeña confusión en
los periodistas que no conocen y no se
informan y no estudian Cómo funcionan
los sistemas en los países en este caso
los detenidos están bajo las órdenes de
los jueces y hay varios tipos de jueces
en este caso hay jueces de instrucción
estas son jueces penitenciarios Son
ellos los que controlan el régimen de
cómo están los detenidos O sea no es el
gobierno o sea el gobierno no puede el
Gobierno no tiene nada que ver cuando
los prisioneros pasan a la orden de un
juez por lo que estamos hablando no
siento que usted está pues muy
convencido del que es el plan de control
territorial de este régimen anti
excepción a pesar de Pues eso no recibir
muchas críticas de estar en el centro de
atención
cuando dicen muchas críticas quisiera
que lo precisara porque yo te puede
decir No hay ninguna crítica entonces
estaríamos en percepciones yo creo que
hay algunas críticas de algunos que
critican todo lo que hace el gobierno y
es entendible que una oposición
el de Colombia Esas son las dos ongs por
eso no son muchas son dos las tenemos
identificadas porque no hay más son esas
dos Entonces no mira lo que sucede en
estos casos es primero no es que estamos
convencidos de que el plan contador de
tierra real va avanzando estamos en la
quinta etapa del plan son siete sino que
y es lo más importante más que lo que
diga Juan papi en Washington o la señora
que está en Londres lo que dice la
comunidad es nuestras la gente que se
siente liberada que estuvo sometida a un
régimen brutal donde las asesinaban
donde tomaban a sus hijas como jainas
sabe que es una jaina somos son esclavas
sexuales que las iban a sacar de las
casas y las tenían en las pandillas
la gente ahora se siente totalmente
liberada complacida y agradecida con el
gobierno por eso es que el 92% según la
última encuesta está respaldando eso
Entonces que me estás repitiendo tú lo
que dice el margen o la parte marginal
de las opiniones Porque si tú consultas
al pueblo salvadoreño no hay críticas
hay reconocimiento y gratitud para el
gobierno y para este plan y usted tiene
una vez se termine el régimen de
excepción Cuál es el plan a largo plazo
para acabar con las causas estructurales
no que llevan Pues a la marginalidad
de hecho eso es una de las grandes
preocupaciones porque como tú dices las
pandillas no surgieron por generación
espontánea es un producto de las malas
administraciones de los gobiernos
anteriores sobre todo después de la
firma de los acuerdos de paz durante la
posguerra cuando los gobiernos
neoliberales de la arena que era el
partido de la derecha que durante 20
años y luego las políticas corruptas del
partido fdn que gobernó los siguientes
diez años generaron todas estas
condiciones en las que la gente sobre
todo los niños de la guerra como
llamamos los huérfanos que quedaron en
familias disfuncionales No tuvieron
ninguna atención del Estado si han
habido violaciones de Derechos Humanos
en para estos niños para estos jóvenes
que no tuvieron ninguna oportunidad es
más el modelo económico que se
implementó en la posguerra fue de
abandonar totalmente la agricultura y
por eso es que se cerraron las los
ingenios los beneficios de café las
plantaciones de café las fincas y la
gente empezó a migrar hacia las ciudades
a generar estos cordones de miseria o
Estados Unidos y ese fue el caldo de
cultivo para que se empezaran a generar
estos grupos que luego se vincularon al
crimen organizado y se convirtieron en
un verdadero poder paralelo al estado
controlaban más del tercio nacional
donde el estado había perdido soberanía
los que mandaban eran las pandillas
ellos ejercían el control y el poder
señor sacaba el tiempo Lamentablemente
pero muy rápidamente le quiero hacer una
última pregunta
usted va por distintos países en
representación No de su país porque
nachipa bukele es tan difícil de acceder
porque él no ha venido a esta Cumbre
porque digamos Usted es la persona a que
nos debemos a referir Si queremos hablar
de lo que sucede en el Salvador siempre
qué te puedo decir él me delega tiene
confianza y todas las cumbres me toca
asistir las a mí esta es una división
del trabajo él está atendiendo
realidades importantes urgentes en el
interior del país usted apoyaría que en
bukele se retirara seis meses antes de
las elecciones Para volver a
representarse a los comicios y usted
quedar en funciones durante ese tiempo
me está preguntando si yo aceptaría que
se cumpla la Constitución bueno que
suceda eso en función es que esos meses
y que él Se volverá a representar eso
eso eso está la Constitución pues te
digo hay un artículo que sea el artículo
152 numeral uno de la Constitución que
es la Norma que habilita al presidente
Para que se pueda presentar a un segundo
mandato siempre y cuando se retire seis
meses la Constitución no habla de bucle
precisamente
se nos acaba el tiempo pero muchísimas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
y a ustedes Muchísimas gracias sigan con
esta y más información en 34 y 34.com